Alright, we've shown you how to load some data
into pandas from a CSV file. Now, let's see if
you can load a csv into python and manipulate the
data in a basic way. What we've provided here is
the skeleton of a function called add full name, which
takes in two arguments, path_to_csv and path_to_new_csv. Assume you'll be
reading in a CSV file with the same columns as
the Lahman baseball data set. Most importantly, there are columns
called, nameFirst and nameLast. Write a function that
reads the CSV located at path_to_csv into a
pandas dataframe, and then adds a new column
called nameFull, with that player's full name. For example,
in the row corresponding to Hank Aaron, nameFull
would be Hank Aaron. After that, write the
data in the Pandas dataFrame to a new
CSV, located at path_to_new_csv. Your code should go here.